hey guys it is Friday which means now is
the best time for you to get all caught
up on what happened this week here's
what matters
it may not be gaming news but eat leaves
significant enough to elbow its way into
this week's recap star wars the force
awakens is now the third highest
grossing film of all time last weekend
the sci-fi blockbuster pulled in almost
146 million globally which now puts its
global box office figures at one point
seven three 3 billion the force awakens
surpassed Jurassic world which formerly
held the number 3 spot on Monday some of
the weekend box office success was due
to the movies debut in China where at
birth records upon its opening on
Saturday the boss awakened still has a
way to go to surpass titanic and avatar
who's overall taking stand at 2.18 6
billion and 2.78 billion respectively
but we'll keep you posted this week
warner brothers released will be combat
pack 2 gameplay trailer showing off the
new characters will be joining the
mortal kombat x roster the brutal
trailer shows off plenty of buddy and
bone breaking action featuring the
expansion packs used fighters
Leatherface from Texas Chainsaw Massacre
the xenomorph from alien for ID show and
try Borg who is a combo of syrax sector
and robots smoke the combat pack 2 also
includes the apocalypse back bigger
character the Brazil pack and both the
cold war and cold war scorpion packs
essentially those will grant you a whole
bunch of new skins earlier this week it
surfaced that Sony had attempted to
trademark the phrase let's play yes this
is pretty much up there with Taylor
Swift trying to trademark the phrase
nice to meet you where you been as
discovered by neogaf Sony file the
application to the united states patent
and trademark office on october 28 it
recently serviced on trademark site
justia which stated that sony hoped to
trademark the term they used in quote
electronic transmission
streaming of video games by global and
local computer networks streaming of
audio-visual and audio-visual material
via global and local computer networks
the trademark office since replied
refusing the trade mug due to the
similarity to one that already exists LP
let's play if he likes for Witcher 3
then you'll love the witcher threes next
expansion which is apparently better new
main games up according to its developer
at a prayer tread senior writer Jacobs
Malik told Eurogamer Italy that's the
upcoming blood and wine expansion has
been created of the back of all of their
experience and fans feedback in creating
the witcher 3 wild hunt as a result of
that he says the team have created
something that is even better than the
main game tomalak makes particular note
of the new charismatic enemy that
players will come up against and the
complex story he thinks people will
enjoy leben wine is a 20-hour story
where guralt heads to a land free from
war where an atmosphere of carefree
indulgence and nightly rituals masks an
ancient bloody secret it's due out in
the first half of this year
finally a microsoft live stream earlier
this week revealed that gears of war 4
is going to launch sooner than expected
the xbox one shooter was supposed to
land in the holiday season of this year
but is now slated to launch in the fall
if that's still not soon enough you're
liking the gears of war for beta is
scheduled to arrive the spring and those
who picked up the gears of war Ultimate
Edition will get to play it first
elsewhere in the live stream microsoft
revealed that forty-five percent of
Ultimate Edition players I'm new to the
gears franchise let me know down in that
comment box where you cared about this
week and if you think Star Wars The
Force awakens can overtake avatar and
Titanic in the global box office this
week on site I give you a super special
behind-the-scenes look at the chest the
full app will show takes a look at
lightsaber and robot mods and we compare
HTC volume to oculus rift that is
everything that I happy this week as
always be sure to have yourselves a
wonderful weekend and I will catch you
again on Monday
you